what if valve threw a party and nobody
came what if they made a new game hyped
it up and a lot of people decided that
it sucked oh and what if it became a
dark stain on the company's legacy one
referred to with both derision and
sadness my point of view everyone pulls
[__] it's almost like a little bit
misunderstood a filete dick it was just
too easy and no we're not talking about
artifact we're talking about
counterstrikes bastard son check this
out okay so to be fair there are
actually a lot of weird [__] CS games
but we don't ever talk about those the
original counter-strike started as a
half-life mod that was later acquired by
valve the game more commonly known as CS
1.6 was released in 2000 and it wasn't
long before it became wildly popular
among FPS fans I tried to sneak through
the door man can't make it can't make it
the [__] stuck
now you have to remember this was back
when valve actually developed games at
the time valve created the then
cutting-edge source engine for its next
generation of titles one of which is
basically the [__] Mona Lisa of PC
gaming half-life 2 but when
counter-strike source was released using
this same engine it failed to capture
much of the competitive community that
was so invested in 1.6 it feels like
maybe that's what happened to a bunch of
1.6 players as they they tried it in
like the first month or something and
they said oh this is nothing like what
I'm used to I'm gonna go back and do one
more 6 and a lot of us did that and then
we never like bridge spend the rest of
the timing in front of the view of link
sauce basically now there was plenty
about the new game that just felt
different probably the first thing that
people noticed was the movement for me
just the fact that you could like run
around and shoot people and source more
than you can on CS like if it was you
have to be a lot more precise and you
have to be perfect like count strafing
making sure you're on point watching RP
cave Frank movies back like he's just
running around on a bomb tower on
Inferno shooting people and you can't do
that anymore is he I don't think you
could run and shoot in source
[Music]
although accuracy was still very bad
while moving and source the reduction of
tagging the slowdown that happens when
you catch a bullet meant that more
people were willing to take their
chances strafing now grenade damage
still caused players to feel like they
were wading through molasses but the
reduction of gunfire tagging was a huge
departure from 1.6 on top of this source
also featured another big change new lag
compensation anytime there's latency
you're gonna see at least some peakers
advantage but a source it meant that
aggressively peeking became incredibly
powerful
so because movement was harder to punish
and peeking was even more powerful
weapons that were capable of killing
with one shot
like the deagle and the OP became
grossly overpowered and the game
environment itself only made those
weapons more effective 14 in favor of a
nexus still kenia's takes unhorsed and
Smith's that's the to Opera's down for
Nexus now there are a lot of other jank
ass mechanics we could talk about when
it comes to source like speed demon
bunny-hopping it's generous hitboxes or
how it's physics engine sometimes made
things broken as hell now I can go on
and on about all of the busted [__]
source I mean we could just get lost
talking about all of it but you can also
get lost in the south anyway the point
is that the competitive community mostly
rejected source after trying it out
garbage sorry wrong clip I play one
places my entire life and when I started
playing source I felt like it was just
too easy my point of view everyone pulls
was was [__] and while source
competition did happen
many of the 1.6 veterans stuck with the
older game which meant that there were
limited eyeballs on source it was tough
to be a contract sauce player because
there was like no money in it
counter strikes competitive community
was split with 1.6 purists claiming that
source was the easier game made for more
casual players I think that's just a bit
of
back then there was a lot of right over
I feel like between 1.6 and sauce and it
was always just like source plays yeah
my games better 1.6 is better like it
was just more so egos and pride coming
into it and while many aspects of source
were tweaks from the release build to
improve its overall experience tensions
within the cs community reached a fever
pitch in late 2005 when one of the
year's biggest tournaments world cyber
games decided to use source and not 1.6
for its counter-strike tournaments
suddenly teams that initially chose to
play source were running up against the
best that 1.6 had to offer and it didn't
go so well one point six crew Team 3d
ran the table against source teams at
WCG 2005 and then defeated the reigning
source champs powers gaming and Everland
winter 2006 damning source players two
years of further torment I have no words
no words to describe the disappointment
I have for every wannabe right now now
despite being largely ridiculed by the
competitive scene source attracted
plenty of casual players and modders in
fact many popular mods like gun game
jailbreak and zombie were either first
developed or perfected on CS source but
after eight years of intense rivalry
between the two scenes everything
changed in 2012 when valve released
Counter Strike global Offensive I think
we needed something to get get
everything together and that was Cisco
they tried to bring the good things from
both of the games and put him in two
years ago at Dreamhack Valencia that
year the best teams from both 1.6 and
source would face off to determine who
was going to be the king in global
Offensive 3 last man standing will be
Nathan he will be taken down and that
will be the first run really quick
although ninjas in pyjamas had players
from both games the all source very
games squad only managed to take second
place you're the number one loser and
sure
back then forest and get rights
dominance might have been the proof 1.6
purists could point at to demonstrate
their superiority over source players
but
it turns out both games have produced
some of CS goes biggest stars look at
the players that have come out of that
game and into account of English couple
offensive you say well it's not that
they were just you know baseline worst
players or anything like some of them
have gone on to be you know some of the
best players in the world basically I
don't necessarily think that it makes me
a worst player to a place or speed but
the fight is not a loss by starting
that's a massive fried eight seconds the
nice go almost
[Applause]
there is a running joke in the team that
most of the players on our team a soft
lace and and the one point six players
quit because they weren't good enough
for csgo so with the developers spending
more time than ever parsing player
feedback it's hard to imagine a future
divided in the counter-strike community
as deep as the one that soars cause I
can't wait to stock why don't you run
back home before this place turns you
into a sniveling mess oh yeah or maybe
you want me to leave so bad because
you're scared you won't be able to keep
up with me your dream I guess we'll see
now boys that's enough squabbling but
without that community clash who knows
if we would even have the global
Offensive that we know and love today I
don't know how anyone played Soros man
that [__] is straight casual trash that
could be worse how you could be a
condition zero player two hours to find
a match great why don't you just play
csgo like us normal people oh I think
the two hour wait [__] degenerate
Matt Massey literally does that every
chute every single I'm immune to it I
literally even I didn't even flinch I
literally said nothing because Matt
masse literally does this every single
shoot boys Africa oh [__] that's like
the first few times if you like really
God people and then literally now it's
just like he'll be mid-sentence or [__]
off